Alright so here's what we're going to do. We're going to try to figure
out how to draw sorry, compute XOR as instead of a single
perceptron, which we know is impossible, we can do it as a
network of perceptron. Just to, to make it easier for you, here's
how we're going to set it up. That we're, we've x1 and x2
as our inputs We've got two units. This first unit is just
going to compute and add and we already know how to do that.
We've already figured out what weights need to be, here and here.
And what the threshold needs to be, so that the output will be
the and of those two inputs. So, that's all good. But ,what we don't
know ,eh, what, what, it turns out to be the case, that the
second unit, with now three inputs, X1, X2, and the and of X1 and
X2, can also be made to, or can be, can be, now, we
can set the weights on that, so that the output is going to be
X or. So, what we'd like you to do is, figure out how to
do that. How do you set this weight - Is the input of X1,
this way which is the and input, and this way which
is the X2 input, and the threshold. So that ,it's going to actually
compute an X or. And, and just so you know, this
is not a trick question. You really can do it this time.